hi
yes yes and with that flower power i say
to thee guess what i fixed the toilet
last night
yes i did i
yeah that's like my bruce lee bada bing
listen i felt like a man last night i
did because you know what most of the
time when stuff like that happens i'm
like oh
help me oh god like but last night i was
like you know what
just lifted the lid off rolled up the
sleeves
went in yanked the chain reattached it
and it worked
i know it's so silly but it's just
oh you know listen we've all had to
learn how to take care of ourselves
in a different way because we're all
stuck in our houses and no one's around
to help
so we got to figure this out and i want
to ask my vffs
has anyone else here had a domestic
everest
that they climbed domestic everest carly
hi hi drew hi ladies
[Music]
right how are you
so excited oh you both look like you're
going to prom
i mean i'm not kidding thank you
gorgeous um did you guys have a domestic
everest you climbed
yes yes we recently moved from southern
california to northern california
and i was missing the la area so i
decided to remodel my master bedroom to
be more like an la vibe i did all by
myself
i mean that really is a domestic everest
mine was more like a domestic
denali maybe a fuji that
is everest i am so impressed good for
you and thank you for
inspiring us to just get it done
you know thank you ladies and you could
not look more beautiful okay
i am so excited for the show we are
talking to a woman
who's turned a cancer diagnosis into a
nationwide
runner's community and i'm actually
going to try and attempt to join this
community myself
so i'm excited to present this to all of
you as an option
and i'm also going to step into the
kitchen and doing a cooking demo
for a dish that is very very important
to me and
satiates something that is sort of a
naughty dish but i found a way to make
it a nice dish
so first um let's kick it off with um
some drew's news we like to serve our
stories here
sunny side up it's true
ma'am i asked you a question
[Music]
it's drew's news
i just really want to thank our vfs
today because
i felt so connected to everyone i mean
really
this is like an awesome crowd today and
every day here is with our vffs i just i
love hanging out with everyone
all right let's kick it off with the
news we try to find the good little
morsels that carry us throughout the day
it's time for history herstory
herstory football that's right this
sunday
for the first time ever three women were
on the field
at an official nfl game okay yeah
that happened at the washington
cleveland game there was
one female coach for each team and one
female referee
officiating the game callie brownson
jennifer king and sarah thomas
i love this story this hurstery
thank you ladies making us all look good
okay next up in the news it's a story
that your stomach cares about because
it's
food news
delish.com reports that nabisco
ding has released their limited edition
maple cream oreo
and it's two golden cookies with maple
syrup flavor
stuffed with the traditional oreo cream
we all know and love i mean if it didn't
have that it wouldn't be an oreo
so i want to try this i met a really fun
friend
in the vff wall jason and
i asked him to come back here actually
we did a
turkey dinner candy corn taste test last
week
and i loved his review so i'm bringing
him back
jason how are ya hi drew
hello i'm great thank you for having me
well i just was like we all love you so
much we were like would jason come back
so thank you you came back
jason right here how do you rock an oreo
uh you know i just i old school fashion
just a little milk you know i let it sit
in there for a little bit
i take it out and eat it but yeah a
little milk i don't have milk for today
i'm just going to say now i'm so
disappointed i should have been
next time we will have uh cold milk
standing by
okay yes yes so uh shall we taste test
these
you ready let's do it here we go
[Music]
cheers
[Applause]
me likey that's fall
yeah falling a cookie it's also like
ihop in your mouth like yeah it's like
yeah it's like maple syrup vermont
party right here yeah like i can't go to
canada anymore because they won't let us
in
so i'm just going to eat these
yeah instead you've got your maple leaf
right here
oh my god these are really good i'm not
kidding these are like
they have almost like that maple smoke
like they are they're just it's
beautiful
wow all right oh god i'm good we have to
move on okay that's really hard to put
down all right
jason do you have the samosas i have
them right here
okay and this has been very difficult
all morning because they have smelled so
good
they're kind of one of my favorite
treats in the world um
fun fact they are a savory indian puff
pastry filled with potatoes and
vegetables
and it's one of my favorite things to
eat and this one
has a pumpkin spiced samosa
trader joe's just released this pairing
that made me go
oh my god
here we go ready let's do it i'm going
hot oh my god
oh my god oh my god i didn't expect that
well i did not expect that this is so
good
that is delicious it's spicy too and the
pumpkin really worked because you
already are used to like a potato vibe
this is yeah by the way trader joe's
food reviews on instagram
are you on that jason anyone it's the
best
it's really good get on it i will get on
it today oh my god this is
so amazing thank you jason
my new from vff to
favorite foodie friend forever that
might be four apps